c'est donc en pleine pandémie que vous
partez à la chasse aux chômeurs
madame la ministre quand allez vous vous
attaquez au chômage plutôt que de faire
les poches aux chômeurs
madame la députée matile panneaux alors
je comprends que ça vous dérange mais
vous n'avez pas le monopole des valeurs
de justice sociale et de solidarité
[Musique]
la justice sociale et l'égalité des
chances sont les combats de ma vie ce
sont vos mots madame la ministre du
travail et à l'heure où les salles de
spectacles sont fermés heureusement que
l'on peut toujours compter sur votre
humour vous allez réduire les
indemnisations pour 40 % des
allocataires est pénalisé en premier les
travailleurs qui enchaîne les contrats
courts plutôt que les entreprises qui
les proposent
ça vous dérange mais aucun gouvernement
n'a agi comme nous le faisons pour
lutter contre la précarité et moi je
suis fière d'être la ministre qui porte
les dispositifs d'activité partielle qui
ont permis de préserver les emplois et
les revenus de près de 9 millions de
français au plus fort de la crise et ce
dispositif madame la députée la majorité
l'a voté vous l'avait rejetée c'est
clair c'est net
[Musique]
ses 15000 traîtres à la patrie qui
planquent un magot de 100 milliards
d'euros avec votre bénédiction
vous êtes le visage à découvert de ceux
qui servent les riches
[Musique]